alicia
is with us in indianapolis hi alicia how
are you
i'm good how are you better than i
deserve what's up
okay so i know consolidated loans are
just piling stupid on top of stupid i
totally get that i understand that
but i need you to hear me out because my
teeth hurts
because what what hurts my teeth hurts
your tooth i have some yes i have some
dental problems that
my insurance will not cover and there is
this company
who was talking about consolidating the
remaining of our 25 000
credit card debt and they would throw in
an extra 10 000 and it would instead of
being 600 that were paying minimum
payments for credit card
it would be 140 something my question is
if i go ahead and do this which i can
then use the 10 000 to fix my teeth
and then instead of paying the 140
they're offering i continue paying the
600 and something actually continue
paying what i'm paying which is closer
to 800.
would that make sense i know
consolidated ones are stupid but it
wouldn't extend my
debt any further because i'm paying it
faster than they expect me too
depending on the interest rate it did
extend your debt by ten thousand dollars
further
you need ten thousand dollars worth of
dental work i'll pull that tooth
it's like it is
i'm sorry it takes how long how much
it's 7 500
to fix every tooth in my mouth and this
one particular one hurts
and the dentist won't touch it because
my insurance won't cover it
i mean i'm sorry one hertz
but 7 500 to fix all of them
oh yeah i i have some sort of a calcium
thing my teeth don't get the calcium
they're supposed to get so they're not
i'm good i'm sorry let me stop a second
i'm just trying to understand all right
i'm not i'm really not trying to be
smart
you have one tooth that's hurting why do
you not remove
that tooth well the dentist doesn't want
to remove that tooth until he can put
some sort of a device in for a bridge
and he won't put the device in for a
bridge until he's done some
deep cleaning or until he's capped these
other two teeth and he won't catch us
with two teeth until he does some sort
of this cleaning thing where they have
to put you out or something and it's
like worse than a regular cleaning
you need to go to a new dentist yes
today you need to go to a new dentist
you need to get some other opinions on
this i'm not a dental
expert okay but um
here's the problem all right you have a
roof leak
and you just call me to buy a whole roof
and finance it instead of just fixing
the leak and i don't know how to do that
in your situation
again i'm not a dental expert if i were
in your shoes i would get at least
two other dentists to look at this
situation
and tell them i'm on a limited budget i
need a temporary
fix until i can save up the money for
the permanent fix
okay i believe in dental work okay and
if
it is truly a 7 500 thing to be done
uh we'll save up the money and we'll get
there and i believe in avoiding pain
i am i mean i'm a complete wuss when it
comes to pain
and so i'm with you on this i'm gonna
pay almost anything to not hurt
because i'm a complete wuss so i'm with
you on all of this
however um this just sounds weird yeah
it does
and it sounds like too alicia that the
debt consolidation company because you
shared this information with them
and they found showed you a way that
emotionally
they can quote unquote try to look like
they're helping you
here's the reality debt consolidation it
is a con
i mean the way that they're able to
lower your your payment is they
extend the length of time that you're in
debt that's the only way there's that
mathematical wizardry there's there's no
what she's saying if she pays the whole
the same 600 it would be out and if the
interest rate is the same
other than the 10 000 you'd be out at
exactly the same time
if you keep the same payment the same
interest rate right but that doesn't
work because you're adding 10 000
to the balance okay i'm not going to
tell you to borrow the money
okay i'm going to tell you you when any
time i'm making a decision
and the only options are the only
options in the decision
suck it means i need more options
you have one option with your dentist
that sucks
yeah you have a tooth that hurts and not
doing something
sucks as an idea and you have this
ridiculous idea to borrow ten thousand
dollars more
by the way you only need seventy five
what we're doing with the other 2500
going to cabo
um so you know uh there's just
i i think you're hurting and i get that
but i'm gonna go get two
other dentists independently look at
this and
most people in dental practices do a
great job i endorse dentists in many
cities around america
on the local radio stations that we're
on and i do so proudly
uh i also have had a few experiences
with them
uh where they're trying to sell me a
bentley and i needed a volkswagen
yeah i actually did have this happen
when i was broke
i had a toothache the year we filed
bankruptcy
and i went to the dentist because i was
hurting because i'm a wuss i didn't have
any money i mean i
didn't know what i was going to do but i
went in there and the guy said i need to
do this is 1988.
i need to do 3 500 worth of work to your
teeth or you're going to lose
all of your teeth within five years
i said well i'm gonna lose all of my
teeth within five years
because i don't have three thousand five
hundred dollars i can't borrow it i'm
just coming out of bankruptcy and um
so i left you know how much of that work
i've had done
how much none seriously 30 years later
every tooth is still in my head so the
guy was a complete
jacked up con wow now i'm not saying
hers is and i'm not saying other types
of
star right that did happen to me and so
i'm always listen anytime you're dealing
with a
professional situation like this an
attorney
a tax person a investment person
a a medical professional you always
get second opinions until you find
options
that fix you that come out of a
treatment plan
that fits your life and your finances
and
that's what you do because they're
counting on
sometimes your emotions and your pain
absolutely just signing in just give it
to me i'll sign it whatever it is just
give it to just stop make it stop i'll
just sign it
right uh that's such good wisdom get a
second or third opinion
just slow down and uh make that call
alicia
that's what i would do i really would
too and get an opportunity to talk to
someone and let them know what's going
on
but all of the things he's suggesting
may have to occur but they might be able
to occur at a different
that's right increments that's right not
all at once
without the debt that's right and
there's all and without the pain
that's yeah that's what i'm challenging
i just it's not logical to me so anyway
it might be wrong i'm not a dental
expert and i really don't even know what
i'm talking about
but i just have lived life a long time
and um
i usually smell fish when something's
fishy yeah
you still got all the same teeth every
one of them
that's impressive i've even got my
wisdom teeth which makes no sense at all
they never even came out seriously
it's crazy uh yeah well so
you know it just was wrong i mean you
know yeah this was wrong
and again but i like that get a second
or third opinion and again take notes
while you're in there
uh be aware uh but that's so true we get
pain going on we can easily get
emotional
i can't um and imagine if you're in with
a family member that you care about
it can be hard to recount some of the
things that are told to you so
i had a kidney stone one time i would
have given somebody a house to get rid
of
you now i did have those when i was 10
and 11.
man i'm telling you you don't you're
just your mind is in a fog no i didn't
forget that i i didn't miss when she
said
my teeth hurt yeah my tooth hurts i'm
tired and
she said it in a way that like it's been
hurting a while and i'm tired of it yeah
and i understand that i appreciate that
i'm sorry yeah i i
that's how i would do it if i were in
your shoes and if you find
three people to tell you exactly the
same thing then you've got a different
challenge
but usually i find i make better
decisions the more options that i have
it's a decision-making tool
gather lots and lots and lots and lots
and lots of options
and the ones that suck will slide right
over to the side the other ones will
be you'll stick you know they'll stand
up right there and you'll go oh one of
those two is a really good idea that's
right
and uh but i often find if i have only
bad options i just don't have enough
options that's true
go back and gather more i like that and
that helps me with almost anything
especially things i don't know anything
about
i'm having to learn something new about
it you know and that's what i'm having
to do if i'm in her shoes there